râper les dents d'un cheval pour éviter
qu'elle ne blessent sa bouche
l'intervention inusité fait pourtant
partie du quotidien de Julia Chamberlain
[Musique]
spécialisé dans les soins aux grands
animaux et nous avait donné rendez-vous
dans ce centre équestre de Montérégie où
son garder une trentaine de chevaux
retentissent finalement on a fini avec
deux ravages dedans puis une dizaine de
vaccins deux hernies ombilicales à
évaluer
cette demi-journée est à l'image de
toute son année Julia Chamberlain est
aussi appréciée que déborder
professionnelle énormément c'est
incontournable on a besoin c'est ça
c'est une nécessité elle s'occupe
d'environ un millier de chevaux et
travaillent souvent 80 heures semaine en
plus d'être sur appel en cas d'urgence
la montée rigie où elle pratique et
malgré tout la région la mieux desservie
de la province au Québec vers Tadoussac
toute la Rive-Nord là ils ont pu
personne du tout pour faire les chevaux
dans ce cas-là
cet été un drame empiré la situation
le 31 juillet la vétérinaire est Keane
s'est enlevé la vie elle avait 36 ans et
était appréciée par 600 clients de
l'Ontario et du Québec
surtout les les chevaux et les chats
il avait beaucoup parlé avec elle de la
lourdeur de sa charge de travail il est
persuadé que c'est la raison principale
qu'il a poussé au suicide une fois
qu'elle a acheté la kiné que j'ai vu un
peu
le stress le fardeau que a commencé à
tomber sur elle
j'ai vu que tu as pu la même personne en
manœuvre
de consulter
mais elle voulait pas parce qu'elle
avait un peu peur de perdre de sa
licence depuis sa mort la clinique
d'Andrea au sud d'Ottawa affirmé
définitivement faute de personnel elle
avait cherché pendant des mois des
vétérinaires pour travailler avec elle
sans jamais les trouver je vais faire en
sorte que son sa mémoire reste en vie
que les gens connaissent qui que c'était
ma copine je veux aussi aider les
prochains parce que vraiment un problème
dans le dans ce secteur là selon une
nouvelle étude 38% des vétérinaires
québécois éprouvent des symptômes
d'épuisement professionnel 16% d'entre
eux ont même eu des idées suicidaires
dans la semaine précédant le sondage à
travers le Canada c'est plus du quart
des vétérinaires qui auraient songés au
suicides en 2020 selon une autre étude
hungry a Kelly n'est pas un cas isolé
sur le coup j'étais un petit peu
bouleversée parce que je me suis quand
même pas un autre puis c'est pas la
première
sûrement pas la dernière je crois
vraiment que c'est respiratoire comme
que je te disais parce que Claudia a
sauvé elle soigne les petits animaux on
le sait la pression que cette fille là
cette vétérinaire là a eu sur les
épaules sa communauté était épuisée elle
aussi surtout depuis la pandémie 60% des
ménages canadiens ont maintenant un chat
ou un chien et on doit refuser des
patients chaque jour ça c'est quelque
chose que je connaissais pas avant il y
a une demande grandissante pour des
vétérinaires mais il y en a pas de
nouveaux vétérinaire
pourtant les jeunes s'intéressent à la
profession mais le programme en médecine
vétérinaire de Saint-Hyacinthe le seul
au Québec est très contingenté 96
étudiants y obtiennent leur diplôme
chaque année une nouvelle formation pour
25 autres verra le jour dans deux ans
Harry Mouski on est limité quant aux
espaces qu'on a à la Faculté de Médecine
Vétérinaire c'est pour ça aussi qu'on a
ouvert encore plus à Rimouski pour
favoriser les régions éloignées où on
fait beaucoup de route on sera sur les
fermes écoute c'est 50 à 55000 kg par
année le défi rappelle Julia Chamberlain
est aussi de garder les nouveaux
vétérinaires quasiment 50% des
vétérinaires qui commencent en pratique
et Kim large la pratique c'est énorme
trop ça trop dur les gardes les fin de
semaine les soirs le psychologique qu'il
faut gérer aussi avec la clientèle
difficile parfois quand elle doit
euthanasier un animal qui la dame qui
est complètement couché sur son cheval
et qui est en sanglot puis moi je suis
là avec ma Franck il faut que je la
pousse le tanné c'est sûr que les larmes
à coule
difficile aussi quand la facture est
élevée les gens ne sont pas habitués de
payer pour des soins médicaux les soins
médicaux sont chers les équipements sont
chers les médicaments sont dispendieux
c'est vraiment l'aspect financier qui
est le plus difficile à chaque jour
constamment on doit s'expliquer on doit
dire pourquoi c'est dispendieux je pense
que tout le monde on entendit la phrase
ouais mais on sait bien vous autres les
vétérinaires vous le faites juste pour
le cash
une révision du programme est en cours
oui on peut s'améliorer pour permettre
au futur médecin vétérinaire d'être
encore mieux équipé pour augmenter la
résilience faire face au stress et aussi
apprendre à mettre ses limites Julien
Chamberlain continue d'adorer son métier
mais elle est parfois about souffle
une chance mon conjoint est là pour me
supporter m'aider parce que sans lui ça
marcherait pas j'ai deux grands garçons
un de 12 ans 9 ans je pense que je
trouve mon équilibre à faire des
activités avec eux
elle nous a salué et reparti soigner
d'autres chevaux
[Musique]